hi my name is Philippe home and I run
the YouTube channel let's talk religion
for about two years now I've been
uploading videos on various subjects
within the field of religion everything
from academic discussions about the word
religion itself to documentaries about
Norse religion in Sweden today two very
complicated videos about philosophers or
mystics like even Arabi religion has
become an increasingly important part of
our social and political discussions and
but in spite of this the knowledge about
religion in the world is very lacking
and thus the discussions we have about
it often are on a very low level so the
aim of this channel has always been and
will continue to be to increase the
religious literacy on YouTube or the
Internet and to provide a source for
academic and trustworthy information on
the subject but as you may imagine
making these videos and this amount of
videos takes a lot of time and energy
everything from writing the script to
shooting the videos to editing them
everything is basically done by myself
which is as I said very time consuming
and very energy consuming and this is
not my main occupation I have a job I
need to make a living and I also aim to
continue my career in the academic field
at the same time but I also want to
increase the quality of the videos on
this channel I want to increase the
quantity I want to make more videos on
obscure philosophers and mystics I want
to make more documentaries about
fascinating local religious groups I
want to make more basic introductory
videos to religious traditions but to do
all this I might need your help so for
all of these reasons I've decided to
create a patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
to certain benefits so I will leave a
link to my patreon page in the
description and you can check it out you
can look at the different options and
make a choice of your own and the
benefits that being a patron will
include is being pray
in choosing the subject for future
videos being able to choose or ask
questions for Q&A videos or live streams
I will be doing as well as exclusive
access to behind-the-scenes footage or
other uploads I will be doing and
previews on future videos not to mention
a more private discussion with me and
other members of the patron community so
if you choose to support me further and
to allow me to continue to do these
videos with frequency and with an
increasing quality I would of course be
very highly grateful so as I said I will
leave a link in description and you can
check it out for yourselves hopefully we
can together increase the religious
literacy on YouTube or in the discussion
on religion in the world generally and I
will also like to take this opportunity
to thank you all so much for your
continual support I'll see you in the
next video